humano pues definitivamente nos hace
pensar en tal vez llegar a las estrellas
y esto quiere decir que el cerebro pues
tiene muchísimo por ser estudiado y
tiene pues muchísimas investigaciones y
propuestas y una de ellas va a ser la de
las neuronas como mecanismo alternativo
de análisis para abordar este tema
invitamos a esteban me lo él es una
economista formada en la universidad
pontificia católica del ecuador con una
maestría en finanzas en el instituto
tecnológico autónomo de méxico además de
experto en dirección de entidades
financieras de la confederación española
de cajas de ahorros y fundación carolina
desde el 2003 es docente de la
universidad andina simón bolívar y es
académica y consultor de la escuela
politécnica nacional en materias
económicos financieras actualmente
evaluador del consejo de educación
superior para la aprobación de programas
de maestrías presentados por
instituciones universitarias y
politécnicas conozcamos un poco más
entonces de neuro finanzas con esteban
de la en gracias
gracias
buenos días con todos
el cerebro humano
peso promedio un kilogramo y medio
capacidad habernos llevado a la luna y
habernos traído de regreso y ahora
seguramente llevarnos a marte y fijar
ahí la primera colonia de seres humanos
fuera del planeta posiblemente hace eso
nos lleva nuestro cerebro en este
momento cada uno de sus cerebros están
generando millones de circuitos
eléctricos una parte de ellos que están
invitando a alejarse de aquí su
pensamiento que vuelve y otra parte
seguramente a poner atención al evento
porque así somos los seres humanos
nuestro cerebro cognitivamente no está
fijado en una sola cosa siempre estamos
viendo por un lado y analizando por otro
lado entonces todo depende de cómo
nosotros lo vayamos ordenando no es
cierto
pensar rápido respuesta inmediata pensar
lento respuesta razonada nuestro cerebro
en la parte de investigaciones de la
economía conductual de la psicología
cognitiva de la psicología social así ha
llegado a determinar se ha llegado a
determinar que tenemos nuestro pensar
rápido y nuestro pensar lento hace unos
días a una amiga le comentaba sobre el
pensar rápido y el pensar lento y ella
me contestaba mira yo soy así
así las respuestas entonces decía qué
pena lamento decirte que no siempre la
solución va por nuestro pensar rápido si
vamos a cruzar la calle aquí estamos
parados a la salida del banco y vamos a
cruzar y el semáforo no funciona ya
tenemos que cruzar rápidamente al frente
vemos que no viene a un auto y cruzamos
nuestro pensar rápido dice cruzar
no estamos calculando la distancia a la
que viene un vehículo que está el fondo
sacando la parábola de la elipse y
multiplicando por la distancia para ver
si cruzó o no eso correspondería a
nuestro pensar lento pero en este caso
hay actividades en la vida que nos
invitan a usar el pensar rápido nos
puede salvar la vida también si nos van
a saltar corre si hay un incendio tan
rápido si uno nos va a atacar también
corramos veamos alguna opción ese es
nuestro pensar rápido el pensar lento
lento no tiene cabida en ese momento
pero también nuestro pensar rápido se
puede volver un asesino yo lo digo así
es un suicida para con nosotros mismos
porque suicida cuantas veces cada uno de
nosotros y lo he pensado aplicando me
siempre en mí hemos pensado
hemos tenido una idea un deseo de algo y
enseguida anulamos con una palabra pero
voy a estudiar pero no tengo dinero voy
a estudiar pero es malo y estoy muy
viejo no lo hice a su tiempo voy a
invertir no pero es mucho riesgo pero
pero pero pero nosotros mismos nos
necesitamos enemigos externos para
aniquilar nuestras ideas
si al menos del 5% de las ideas que
tuviésemos realmente las pasáramos al
pensar lento y las ejecutamos otra
historia sería la nuestra
un ejercicio muy simple si un bate de
béisbol junto con su pelota cuestan un
dólar 10 y el bate de béisbol cuesta un
dólar más que la pelota cuánto cuesta la
pelota contestemos a ustedes mismos
entonces esta actividad del cerebro del
pensar lento nos lleva a tomar
decisiones más razonadas y más pensadas
entonces nuestro cerebro genera la idea
la pasamos al análisis de la parte
rápida al pensar lento y analizamos y
avanzamos de esa manera
en 1737 un economista famoso
investigador de economía el señor bernal
y sacó su teoría de la utilidad teoría
que la hemos venido estudiando todas las
generaciones de quien nos hemos dedicado
economía en las finanzas
y a cerca de 300 años de la teoría todo
fue aceptado y que decía la teoría que
decía bernouilli más allá de las
fórmulas en un ejemplo muy sencillo si
juan y lupita tiene cada uno 500 dólares
y va a invertir el análisis de la teoría
de la utilidad decía a veces vamos a
analizar las inversiones que hacen juan
y lupita
500 dólares invierte juan 500 dólares
invierte lupita y bernal y empieza a
hacer todo su análisis en función de la
actitud de las decisiones posteriores
que van tomando en este tema de
inversión pero casi 300 años después
aproximadamente unos 270 años luego de
la vigencia de esta teoría
se aplicó algo que se llama la ceguera
inducida de la teoría la seguida
inducida de la teoría que dice si hay un
planteamiento de una teoría en un año
las revistas en todas las citas en tres
peor si pasan diez años ya nadie la
cuestión es pasando 150 años imagínense
es una realidad pero santificada
pero hubo una persona que vio la teoría
y dijo no aquí hay un error craso
evidente cuál era el error
el punto de referencia porque juan el
día anterior había tenido 100 dólares y
cuando parte el análisis bemol y tenía
500 o sea había ganado 400 a diferencia
de lupita que el día anterior había
tenido mil dólares y ahora tenía 500
entonces no se puede analizar el tema de
la utilidad ni la actitud sobre la
inversión de dos personas que
psicológicamente en su cerebro no son
comparables la una venía golpeada por
una pérdida la otra eufórica por una una
ganancia entonces nace la teoría de las
perspectivas quien la genera es daniel
kahneman daniel kahneman el año 2002 por
esto que les digo ganó el premio nobel
de economía es 2002
y sorprendamos no era economista era
psicólogo primer psicólogo o sea persona
no economista que gana primero doble
en un más en unos eventos que organizaba
el banco hace algunos años
participe con un grupo de compañeros en
uno de estos eventos que para trabajar
en equipo y eso bueno fui a vamos a
trabajar en equipo que los deje trabajar
en equipo que vamos juntos que caminemos
y así otros de la bola pro gradiente a
todos los típicos de ejemplo es tan
bueno estaba ya sí que tendría pero
medio aburrido luego del almuerzo se me
acerca el instructor
shaka shaka una castilla de fósforos y
fósforo días seguidas dije tabaco pues
nueve invitando un cigarrillo
el caballero eso dijo mi pensamiento
rápido es relacione a fumar saco luego
no prendió una encendió ni me dijo nada
y sólo me expreso me dijo toma este
zedillo y regresas en una hora tuve un
viertes nada de dinero y quiero ver cómo
los negocios y que me traes
la siguiente acción mía fue reírme cómo
va a plantear una cosa tan absurda un
pensamiento rápido luego dije bueno ya
tocó y le dije empezar a trabajar
dejen que empiece a trabajar mi
pensamiento centre digo porque no en
resumen en una hora regresé con una
pelota de básquet nueva en una red nueva
y le entregué al instructor y se quedó
viendo me y me dijo imagínate si en una
hora me traes de esto cuando te dio ese
vídeo que me hubiese extraído en un mes
en un año ese fue un punto de inflexión
en mi vida personal definitivamente esa
pelota la guardé y siempre a mis hijas
tengo mis hijas siempre les indicaba la
pelota y les contaba comentaba la
historia
aquí hay el tema de lo que nosotros
conocemos como el pensamiento lateral
y tenemos la palabra heurística la
heurística viene del griego de la
palabra eureka se acuerdan que
arquímedes estaban sumergidos en una
tina salió y vio que se regaba agua
entonces él sacó el tema de la densidad
de los objetos sumergidos porque el rey
el ión en siracusa mandó a construirse
una corona de oro con un kilo de oro
pero cuando le pegaron el nudo y dijo no
de pronto aquí hay una aleación y me
están estafando entonces quien ayuda fue
donde el matemático a explicar a que le
explique y que le ayudará a solucionar
esto entonces cuando encuentra
arquímedes la solución sale desnudo
corriendo así es la historia y grita
europa que significaron completa y viene
la palabra heurística que significa
encontrar experimentar buscar y eso nos
lleva a la inteligencia emocional y al
tema del pensamiento lateral para las
invenciones yo cuando salgo de paseo con
mis hijas trato de vez en cuando hacer
desde ejercicios de pensamiento lateral
para que ya se vayan ejercitando en eso
es la heurística en buscar el investigar
el ver algo diferente
cuando cuestionamos una teoría
cuestionamos lo mismo que por ejemplo en
nuestro trabajo
cuántas veces llega un joven con alguna
idea al trabajo y le dice a las personas
que están ahí saben que yo tengo ni idea
porque no hacemos esto y qué es lo que
lo que es decimos así siempre se ha
hecho pues ese es el método así funciona
así hemos dicho siempre
ceguera inducida de la teoría aplicado a
un tema laboral
en las de euros finanzas se ha
demostrado científicamente que en la
recompensa a la euforia de haber ganado
no es tan intensa como la pérdida de
haber perdido la misma cantidad de
dinero más eufórico me siento con 100
dólares que gane pero resulta que si los
pierdo la sensación de fracaso es mucho
mayor y es un elemento a tomar en cuenta
cuando realizamos o hacemos algún tipo
de inversión y que debemos siempre
considerar
gracias